je m'appelle simon j'ai une vie
parfaitement normal sauf que j'ai un
énorme secret des moufles
je m'appelle simon et je suis comme toi
j'ai une vie parfaitement normal sauf
que j'ai un énorme secret de nous je
crois que suis amoureuse de toi
super je regarde personne c'est que je
suis gay
toi tu as déjà été amoureux je crois
tu mérites pouvoir tout ce que tu
souhaites
c'est parti la fête s'est bien passé
génial jamais l'emporter agi d'être
femme en laine presse et il est bourré
je m'appelle ciment et je suis comme toi
j'ai une famille normale des amis
géniaux un lycée banal
qu'est ce que tu fais pas textos dans
les couloirs je ne peux pas laisser mes
étudiants à aller sur kindle c'est mon
domaine
j'ai une vie parfaitement normal sauf
que j'ai un énorme secret de mousse
salut nouveau poste
je parle de les léguer à l'école je
crois que c'est qui
cher blue je suis comme toi mais
personne c'est que je suis gay gilles
simon c'est bon de savoir qu'un autre
garçon lisse et partage le même secret
quand est-ce que tu l'as eu cher blue il
ya une série de petites choses comme ma
première petite amie et je crois que
c'est toi je reviens ça n'a pas été mon
heure de gloire je vous tends à parler à
quelqu'un ment blue j'en ai parlé à
personne
quoi qu'on en dise révéler aux autres ce
qu'on est et terrifiant habits celle la
plus sexy que j'ai jamais vu c'est pas
vraiment mon genre
pas parce que les noirs j'adore les
femmes noires enfin pas comme tu adores
toutes les femmes gèrent blue c'est très
injuste que seuls les gains doivent
faire leur coming out
imagine un peu il faut que je vous dise
quelque chose je suis hétéro j'aime les
filles quoi tu veux ma mort
[Musique]
on regarde tout de suite son ordinateur
quelqu'un publié tj mail sur le blog du
lycée je regrette simon je peux plus
continuer
[Musique]
c'est moi qui suis censée décider où
quand comment et qui le sait comment je
peux le dire c'est quelque chose qui
m'appartient
suite genre de personne qui est destiné
aimait tellement une personne qui ça
pour end et horaires - si j'te santé
retenir sa respiration
tu es toujours toi simon
mata déjà être l'amour je sais pas je
crois cher blue je ne sais peut être ni
tour n'ont ni à quoi tu ressembles mais
je veux trouver
j'en peux plus de vivre dans un monde je
peux pas être qui je suis sorti avec moi
parce que tu trouves que je ressemble à
un garçon en fait j'ai rempli avec toi
parce que tu ne ressembles par ailleurs
d'accord merci
non rien